manoir bonjour et merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france à leur
nouvelle mobilisation hier contre la loi
c'est qu'ils ont été global on a observé
moins violente mais surtout un
dispositif policier impressionnant 3000
policiers et gendarmes ont été déployés
à paris c'est presque 50% de plus que la
semaine dernière elle s'agit-il d'une
nouvelle stratégie en terme de maintien
de l'ordre
vous l'avez bien dit de 5000
manifestants à paris 3000 effectifs des
forces de l'ordre donc on est à plus
d'un policier pour de manifestants pour
pouvoir assurer l'ordre républicain dans
la capitale donc si vous voulez en
démocratie c'est un aveu d'échec en
réalité parce que on en est à se
satisfaire qu'une manifestation se soit
déroulée sans dégâts matériels est passé
non sans un brin parce qu'il y a eu des
années des heurts entre manifestants et
policiers
mais quand on en arrive à devoir
déployer plus d'un an
un policier pour de manifestants c'est
pour un manifestant et demi plus
précisément je trouve qu'en démocratie
c'est quelque chose qui sonne comme un
aveu d'échec en réalité parce que vous
imaginez bien que les policiers et tous
les dispositifs de maintien de l'ordre
ont toutes un coût financier et ce coût
serait plus à même en ce moment d'être
réinvesti dans des causes plus utiles
comme le renfort des commissariats le
renfort des services publics en général
dans des quartiers sensibles par exemple
effacer les primes des grandes villes où
les gens sont en demande de sécurité
voyez on a autre chose à faire avec la
police et la gendarmerie que de déployer
finalement ses effectifs sur des
manifestations qui sont en réalité tout
à fait légitime si elle se passe bien
elle porte une contestation de la loi
sécurité globale que le gouvernement
devrait entendre un dispositif renforcé
pour justement éviter que éviter la
casse puisque les précédentes semaines
on a vu beaucoup de commerces dégradés à
cause des black blocs qui sont présents
c'est ce qu'il faut justement
aujourd'hui pour pour prévenir cette
violence pourquoi où on n'essaye pas de
prévenir en amont puisque on sait qu'à
chaque manifestation il ya ces groupes
des personnes qui vont à valence assuré
dans la mobilisation
tu vous poser la question mais au risque
de vous décevoir moi j'ai pas vraiment
la réponse parce que ça fait deux ans
qu'on nous a vanté la mise en place d'un
fichier anticasseurs donc on nous a
assuré que les services de renseignement
étaient extrêmement performant qu'on
avait dressé la liste des casseurs et
qu'on allait les assignés à domicile les
jours de manifestation il n'en est
absolument rien on est on en est à
déployer des moyens colossaux moi je
serais très curieux
par exemple de poser la question au
ministre de l'intérieur de savoir quel
est le bilan financier de l'encadrement
de ces manifestations depuis plus de
deux ans maintenant je pense que ça se
chiffre en milliards d'euros sans aucune
difficulté
donc après prévenir effectivement la
casse écoutez je pense que au regard des
images
moi je peux pas
si vous voulez me dire avec une avec
assurance aujourd'hui que les forces de
l'ordre n'y sont pour rien un mois hier
j'ai regardé par images interposées
cible et j'ai vu des charges policières
sur des citoyens qui manifestaient
paisiblement des coups de matraque à
voter des jets de gaz lacrymogène qui
interviennent de façon totalement
hasardeuse sur des gens qui n'ont mois a
priori rien fait pour d'aucuns prennent
ensuite on parle de re de casse etc
moi je suis pas certain que la police
soit totalement irréprochable et
d'ailleurs la communication
ministérielle met en avant la
gendarmerie et elle met police juste
derrière parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui
pouvoir apaiser et on va dire augmenter
le niveau de popularité de la police on
met la gendarmerie à côté alors qu'on
sait très bien que ça n'a rien à voir un
peu pas de ce point de vue là le
mélanger police et de gendarmerie
donc voilà on se j'ai regardé les tweets
du ministre de l'intérieur donc on se
satisfait d'avoir pu intercepter un
tournevis et je crois une clé à molette
restants ou écouter c'est une
communication que je trouve très
honnêtement à laquelle j'ai même pas
envie de m'intéresser en réalité parce
que le problème de fond c'est la loi
sécurité globale c'est l'esprit de cette
loi
d'ailleurs j'apprends par à votre
antenne qu'on a interdit la
manifestation à toulouse bond cde
pourquoi est-ce qu'on interdit à des
gens de manifester
ouais c'est très complexe en fait comme
canevas et j'ai pas du tout envie de me
concentrer si vous voulez là où on
demande d'aller voir j'ai je préfère
rester sur l'essentiel et savoir ce
qu'il en est cette loi et savoir
pourquoi est ce qu'on refuse obstinément
à coups de matraque de réviser notre
copie au ministère de l'intérieur
justement vous avez parlé de ses charges
policières contre des manifestants qui
ont été là paisible dans certains
députés et journalistes d'ailleurs ont
dénoncé une dérive autoritaire
oui bien sûr mais je pense que c'est pas
la première fois c'est pas la dernière
fois qu'on dénonce eux ces violences et
ces dérives
maintenant si j'ai déjà de laisser un
message
à d'autres canaux médiatiques aux
manifestants moi je pense qu'ils doivent
faire l'économie de leur argent leur
énergie et leur santé on sait très bien
que jusqu'à 2022
il n'y a aucune perspective de
changement le gouvernement a décidé le
passage en force de ces textes et
d'autres réformes
il va donc falloir se concentrer sur
l'horizon 2022 et demander à des
candidats crédibles de s'engager sur une
volonté de changement profond et de
réformes profondes de l'institution
police si vous voulez actuellement on
n'aura pas le contrôle de la police et
des forces de l'ordre
il faudra passer par une voie par la
voie démocratique pour reprendre le
contrôle de cette institution
il reste environ un an la campagne des
présidentielle commencera d'ici quelques
mois et il faudra se concentrer sur la
campagne présidentielle mais d'ici là si
on peu épargné à certains manifestants
de se retrouver et fournier emprisonnés
et où voir mutilé ce je pense qu'il faut
pas en faire l'économie parce que le
gouvernement est pas du tout ce ne se
trouve pas du tout dans une logique de
dialogue à l'heure actuelle et tout le
reste finalement n'est que mauvaise
littérature et n'est que de gâchis en ce
qui concerne les manifestants merci
beaucoup un homme noir d'avoir réagi
avec nous ce matin je rappelle que vous
êtes délégué syndical on dit merci